So if you remember from the original example, Pavlov was a neutral stimulus. So
a neutral stimulus is a stimulus that originally produces no specific response
other than perhaps an orienting response, meaning the dog looked at Pavlov.
Next, we see that Pavlov repeatedly paired his sight with the meat power, thus
the meat power was an unconditioned stimulus. Remember, an unconditioned
stimulus is a stimulus that automatically causes a reflex to occur. The meat
powder caused the dog to salivate. Here, the salivation is an unconditioned
response. Remember, an unconditioned response is something that occurs
automatically in the presence of a particular stimulus. Now remember in the
beginning Pavlov was repeatedly paired with the meat powder. Then when he came
by himself and did not give meat powder, so Pavlov became a conditioned
stimulus. A conditioned stimulus is a previously neutral stimulus that comes to
elicit a response due to its pairing with an unconditioned stimulus. So when
Pavlov approached the dog as a conditioned stimulus, It caused a conditioned
response, and a conditioned response is one that occurs in the presence of a
condition stimulus presented alone. So, here, the sight of Pavlov was the
condition stimulus, the salivation was the conditioned response.